you have a surfed on a shark i like
shocks yes and i like surfing
surf shark uh a vpn service do you know
what that means
it's an app or a web browser extension
nailed it first time didn't have to
really take that
no it allows you to put your laptop or
your mobile phone whatever anywhere in
the world yeah whatever device it is
that you've installed it on because you
can install it on multiple devices
that's what makes it different to other
vpns because they all have to be just
one for one one for another one you have
to keep re-buy this slot this one
size fits all brilliant yeah and you
love that the point is with it if you
want to put your laptop anywhere in the
world then you can
not physically but internetly definitely
it's definitely convinced as the world
wide web
yeah of untruth yeah you ever been on
the world by bobby brian i know you have
because you've got tisch
it basically lets you access uh
sometimes block websites if those
websites are blocked in your country
and also i'm not sure if it's just about
kinky sometimes it's political
so for instance the example that i
always think of is if you want to watch
netflix but netflix from another country
say america where netflix is
particularly good put surf shark on
boom you're absolutely wrong yeah
fanny's your aunt
all thanks to surf shark basically that
puts you in that country so you can go
i think i watch some netflix from
vietnam tonight
you've seen the platform which is like a
spanish movie that they've done their
voice over where the food goes down
yeah yeah people are trying to climb up
their good
yeah spanish netflix would be good and
it also works vice versa so say you go
to another country you know you don't do
that often
yeah spain because you love spanish
netflix you can go back and go i
want to watch bbc tonight sure with this
vpn that's what you can do can we use
something else because that could be
ticking
for other things these days with your
dirty mouth as you said to me i want to
watch lots of bbc
tonight yeah so if you want it which you
probably do after all that
uh use my code geordie i check out get
85 percent
yeah i've got that wrong yeah i always
think that at 85.
it must be 15 off but you know it's 85
off and three months three extra for
free
wow surf shark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you're not
happy
there's no risk but the likelihood of
you being unhappy is but the rewards
yeah imagine all the spanish netflix so
if you want it hit the link in the
description below
and enjoy but for now it's time for true
news
[Music]
[Applause]
is everything all right i'm fine right
then what are you doing here looking at
stephen
yeah and why stephen looking at you
that's wonderful right a bit scared
yeah so what's happening in this picture
i heard stephen was in trouble
right and you went over to help is that
why you're dressed as a commando i don't
know i just dig that shirt yeah my time
it was the thing
it was my shirt yeah it was my thing
yeah you're dead but relax man don't
touch me
don't touch me because i'm going to get
a person don't talk to me
i think you need a [__] call in the
[__] someone came over to the table they
went steven's in trouble you went
i'm on my way i thought it was in actual
trouble i didn't realize he was having
he didn't realize he was talking i
didn't actually know what he was saying
i thought it was actually kicking off
right so you hadn't
observed this from a distance for a
while and gone probably timeout i just
seen a crowd
as if it was a fight you heard there was
a rap battle going on and you got over
there as fast as you just see this
yeah his arms were heavy when i got in
there i was like
is this nothing okay this is nothing
yeah yeah yeah and then you just went
[__] off let's leave when i watched it
but i was like stephen tries just to be
[__] clear
in my opinion is in the top five most
talented youtubers
there is so to question his talent and
where he's going in his career this
isn't even a good
insult like you're just you're just
wrong it's just like it's just like
wrong
you think your mate's in trouble you
just get in don't you just sort of get
involved
while everyone else was going you went
is everyone all right here and i think
you're actually checking because you
heard he was questioning stephen's
ability you went
you all right yeah are you mentally ill
what people don't need to know
but probably should know is that this
has happened quite a lot anyway with you
you've broken up a lot of fights it's
just it just so happened to be
cameras i i i sort of stopped them
before they happened yeah yeah because
if you hit my me
then i'm gonna have to hit you and then
that's going to be that's going to be me
in prison and also i imagine you went oh
sorry you're the problem
oh okay goodbye he threatened to shank
people this man
imagine going to a corporate event at
wembley
for charity for charity right for
charity and ee
and going i will shank you i actually
when i watched the video about i
realized as i got to the exit door with
steven
around stephen yeah uh he then was like
you [__] [__]
i watched that i was like why didn't you
say that to my face not only that but
you weren't even that fat at that point
thank you very much yeah well i'm not
anymore because i've just exactly losing
weight as you've seen hashtag
rebuild yeah it was a no not really a
thing is it to be fair i don't give a
[__] about any of this um
welcome back to true news we've missed
you good morning by the way or good
afternoon or good evening
uh wherever you're at uh around the
world right now i wanted to give you
guys
a little helpful update on some of the
things that i have been going through on
my end
my wife lauren as well as my two baby
girls
and myself we have all tested positive
for covert 19.
i'm sorry right yeah it's not funny i'm
sorry i'm not sure why the reason why
i'm laughing is because when i had covey
i was just an absolute stinking sweaty
coughing
disgrace of a person like the amount of
sweat coming off my body
like i was having to lie down on a towel
you thought you'd wet yourself in my
yeah in my bed
it was i probably had weapons no i
hadn't but the point is if you'd asked
me to like
tell you guys to address the nation i
would have just been like
i'm dying i wouldn't the news
is this uh me my kids my wife we've
tested positive
for kovit 19. like if this guy shot
himself on a train going somewhere not
that that that's happened to me in the
last round
why are you talking about that that's um
unusual that's what
i'm saying poke the pants out the window
literally right
he he'd be like to the world i want you
to know that i have
[__] myself and it really is sticky down
there
and i've gone through some doozies in
the past i've gotten knocked about and
got my ass kicked a little bit in the
past
yeah you got beat at wrestlemania mate
[__] hell that must have been a real
low for you because that looked painful
what stone cold did to him
well yeah the song called stunner is
yeah on a par with corvid
yeah i think if you ask most people what
would you rather take yeah corvid
yeah i do not want to get kicked in the
gut and then broken your nose
on a shoulder yeah that looked like it
really hurt yeah exactly he was bouncing
around afterwards i was like
wow practically backflip across the seat
there yeah it was amazing and then the
three cone yeah kicked oh
unbelievable unbelievable if you can
kick out with that he can kick out a
corvid
yeah i guarantee you next week boris
johnson goes on
he goes
but testing positive for covert 19 um is
much different than
overcoming nasty injuries or or
are being evicted being affected
being affected i think he just i love it
and then
having to be in a movie with that
[__] vin diesel
oh no to be fair that's a pleasure
though
they don't get vendors on the rocks how
can vin diesel and the rock they don't
get on is it because they go
you're doing my thing this is it
basically they were having a beef
and i just got in the middle i went is
everyone all right everyone all right
yeah all right [__] it
man like diesel over here yeah because
steven's definitely and the reason why i
feel like this is different is is
because
my number one priority is to always
protect
my family so that's the unfunny thing
you can't fight corvid though
if kovid's in the ring and then suddenly
hear the rock music and he's just like
oh my god jerry the king lawler ghost
rock is cooking do you know what he's
cooking he's cooking the cure
that's what he's been doing by the way i
know i speak for all of you guys it is
our
number one priority all of you guys
around the world you always want to
protect your family and your babies
you want to protect my family and my
babies i always want to protect all of
you guys yeah
you didn't actually save the world
either yeah you jumped out with a
helicopter just a question what's your
favorite rock film
i did like walking tall right remember
that rocks movies aren't great are they
that's a critique and if you ever want
to come on the podcast you'll even
promote one of them what would be fine
with that
we love the guy yeah but what we can
honestly say we love what the rock says
he's not a method actor
right you know when you look at al
pacino going from godfather scarface
yeah you've got it in you to do
different roles the rock has been the
rock
his whole life no that's where you're
wrong he is a method actor he walks in
the meeting they go you be the rock and
he goes let me tell you this
yes and they all go oh brilliant we're
on the other side we are no longer
contagious and we are
thank god we are healthy and we've
gotten through covert 19
stronger and healthier yes that's almost
medically impossible that is one of
those things where you say it not
actually true
yeah your lungs are totally death right
i didn't i didn't feel strong
no yeah you didn't come out the other
side and go i'm better what makes you
bad makes you a better ass i'll have
another dose
yeah if he does become president can we
get someone to help them on science
yeah i mean that's what most presidents
need they're not presidents you know
what we need is better science
we'll need a combination of better
science there's no better science
anywhere
we're just gonna pull better science at
your [__] fat ass better
[__] science that sounds like a bad
memory to me now do you know what i mean
yeah that seems like so long ago that
that was said but
hard prime minister any other role we
just we'd sack you
next up if a toddler designed a rapper
it would be this
six nine
[Music]
huh is she actually naked with sprinkles
on her can we have a little no she's not
actually naked she's
no i think she's actually wearing
underwear under the sprinkles
yeah look she's got underwear is
sprinkles the go-to though for an
uh i don't know what candy this is true
news
what would you put on arses though
underwear to make it sweeter
right i prefer the natural taste you
can't pop like this
everybody want my sweat everybody want
my drip
if jake paul made this song we'd be
saying this is awful to be fair we're
saying this is awful now
yeah i know i'm just this is awful jake
paul's last song no need new friends i
don't like fake friends only here to
make ends call when they check in it was
way better than this oh yeah it was yeah
yeah i mean that that's actually
true this is all a big act and then he
goes to bed at night and he's like okay
goodnight honey he's not an interesting
i think his big bodyguard would probably
carry him to the yeah he goes down six
nine is ready for bed now
and then they put him in his little
jammies always talking about me cause
you looking for the clout
quite a feminine walk yeah i imagine
when you do a feminine walk you're a
hard man
then it's sort of it's actually showing
how hard you are i'll try those
yeah yeah next time i'm breaking the
fight i'm just going to come in like
this yeah you'll go
is everyone okay over here hi guys
at least he's masked up he's put his
mask
on a bit low there that's when you know
he's hard yeah he's got his mask on his
chin
yeah wristing rule breaker i think the
rock would have a fit
[Music]
what do you think they're trying to
imagery wise laurence you're a director
clean women
clean pure women members and milk yeah
do you remember cleopatra yeah i heard
she used to do that
yeah we uh we had a chat rough back in
the day yeah
uh did she message you on instagram she
did yeah i was like
i'm bathing in milk for me bathe in this
semen you said
i'll fill a bath it's going to take
about a month to be fair by that time
it's prob that's going to be quite a
smell
quite at that point yeah for you just to
be clear if you're wondering what we're
getting out there we're talking about
brian
coming into a bathroom consistently
which is apparently very good yeah
chef's kiss so
listen most women come up and go that
was a wonderful blog your brian brian
looks down and he goes it's a me
a brian to be fair i do have a lot of
italian food so by that point
yeah there's a lot of olives and sort of
aged meat
you cured me yeah so like my age just to
be clear we're not talking about my
penis
because that's in its price yeah exactly
in its prime and it's not cured
no it doesn't need cured from anything
nice tell your needs cured the rock
16's over that's the conclusion it was
good while it lasted
if i love rap music and i love big
horses but i'm bored of you
yeah and that's what you deliver you
know you've got problems yeah yeah
exactly you're [__]
i would interview david blaine in a
heartbeat because he's done some
kind of wild [__] in the past but
magicians i always feel like there's
something
not right with them yeah well that's the
point of a magician isn't it they're
magicians just missed a few hugs when
they were a kid so they try to do magic
tricks to get their parents to like
i'm really not sure david blaine's
trying to get you to like you like that
yeah yeah
oh sorry on the approval so yeah yeah
basically magicians are deeply
seeking that adulation and approval
there's people who
whether it's magicians or tricksters or
tal like
britain's got talent lot or whatever ah
right like now you think [__]
no but no but what i mean is i much
prefer like athletes
or like someone who can sing or like
real talent to me like rather than oh
you did a trick there i feel like this
is something you should talk to with
your therapist
like we've had a lot of people who want
to come on the podcast and it's like do
magic
this no but like their thing is like a
trick or whatever and i'm like yeah but
once you've done the trick it's like
it's done now isn't it we had joe rogan
put in the nice and i was like that's
great but this is a podcast like i want
to know more about your
we could watch that wherever we've
watched a e before we've all seen like
people have operations
we know we get it metal can go through
skin
i get that there's no one on a e going
in going look what i did
yeah hey my [__] leg
it's coming up that's the point though
though he's like he's not doing that
he's just literally putting a little
needle through his arm
a little needle through his arm it looks
it looks uncomfortable but
we know you're not gonna die bro like
it's fine let's have some conversation
you know let's find out more about your
upbringing and why you desperately crave
approval it's weird i'm not quite sure
what this was
in the description brian it says this
have you ever had
a dream so vivid you knew it had to be
real watch ascension free
with ads or get youtube premium to watch
ad free
with exclusive bonus footage the ads
disappear dude
what a dream this this video which
youtube
really got behind you know uh we we've
tried to do our best you know make a
documentary recently
put some effort into it but this guy um
you need to fly strap themselves to some
balloons
yeah yeah that would have been me yeah i
wouldn't shoot yourself i wouldn't have
liked that right you know
i would have loved it credit to them it
was a spectacle but at the same time it
was also like why are you trying to make
it like you're hanging on by one hand
when you're really
belted to this whole thing i'm not quite
sure what the magic bit was
what's the magical part he's just flying
on some balloons
that's not flying that's falling with
style and what i want to do is i want to
grab
that rig of balloons and i want to go
floating
all the way up into the sky until i
become a little dot in the sky that
you're going to see
oh we'll see now you know kids when they
have sort of weird parents
almost become the parent themselves yeah
you know when the parent goes
and i'm the guy that's gonna and you go
oh will you
okay she's patronizing her very michael
jackson
right yeah he talks a bit like michael
jackson sometimes where you're like grow
up mate
you
like why are you jumping on some
balloons me like what the [__] are you
doing
i'm fascinated by him there is a point
in this video apparently where the
daughter says something like none of
your tricks are real
i haven't done anything since you were
one years old
and i stopped fake things no fake like
scary things
yeah she's out in there she's dropped a
minute there yeah you've not done any
fake things since i was born i mean
scary things since i was born we could
have done a rehearsal for this couldn't
we
yeah instead they went now we'll be fine
don't worry about it he's magical
nothing ever goes wrong with kids and tv
that's one thing we do know well this
isn't tv bryan it's youtube originals
a new variation on tv which people can
subscribe to now link
yes they haven't given us that youtube
originals money sadly we have to
make our own documentaries to our own
money into it to help
make the platform better with actually
high quality
live streaming equipment and whatnot but
you know it's fine
we consistently demonetize what we
consistently try and make the platform
better but it's it's
let's just watch the man float in the
balloons who's really taking the
platform to new levels of course because
he's helping people with
mental health by escaping their problems
on planet earth right okay what was that
because of you i wanted to do something
beautiful but that's not dangerous
no but this is the first one that i'm
doing that's beautiful and that's
all because of you it's true
i feel like he's looking into her eyes
and trying to connect with her and
because the
relationship i'm jumping the conclusions
here i might be completely wrong but
right they
they're not coming across as a normal
father-daughter relationship because ten
minutes ago he went
oh it's a frog with you again oh yeah
she is about to watch her dad take off
into orbit yeah and let's be honest if
someone did that for me i'd go
how much budget to spend on this because
i think i preferred the car do what
other dads do and give me a sweet 16 car
in prom dress or whatever
i love this is that he's going for you
i'm gonna take off on a set of balloons
she goes what's that doing for me
what i'm just standing here watching you
fly over
i think he's trying to find a way to
make a reason for him to do this and
this is what they've come up with yeah
maybe it could be for your daughter
yes
for the protection of our brother
david blaine is he experienced and
people setting themselves off with
balloons yeah
is that his thing yeah i've done a
million of these well yeah
well youtube red no problem i normally
do bar mitzvahs what it's uh
200 all right yeah yeah that's what my
normal brand yes
dear root yep good yeah i found that was
youtube i added three zeros
absolutely yeah do you know what that
little that little thing reminds me of
this yeah
[Music]
i feel sorry for this little girl's face
man i like her no
she's my favorite character she does
look a little bit worried now it might
seem simple but in reality there are
some serious risks
if there's a balloon failure before i
put on my parachute i can go crashing to
the ground
if he doesn't put on his parachute he
dies if he doesn't put on his parachute
there's people on parachuting every week
yeah i think what he had to do was put
the parachute on in mid-air
well you're just making it more complex
for the sake of it and that's not an
actual danger you're creating danger
yeah for the sake of it what would be
great
is if we coated those balloons in bird
seed
you know the way they did that with that
with the ostrich six nine get six nine
nine he goes higher load of birdseed
on the balloons right we'll see how long
your last stone yeah everybody's good to
go
we're good is everybody good yep are we
good to go
love you that's gonna take me up
gave her a present before he went away
that's nice what do you think it was as
will
that would freak me the [__] out i don't
like heights
oh okay i would love this yeah would you
like yeah yeah i love heights
that's very grand theft auto yeah looks
good and david you don't have to answer
anything i say just informing you that
we're about 17 000.
we've passed the helicopter limitations
the helicopter can't hang with you
anymore
seventeen thousand feet it's kind of
mental though i mean to be honest with
you now you're in me over a little bit i
wanna see where he jumps then
24 wait 200 more feet wait 200 more feet
i said weight 200 more feet imagine when
you let go someone was wait
yes do you know what's funny though when
they go on about the world being
uh earth being flat and all that it does
look like a perfect straight line there
doesn't it yeah that's cause you can't
see far enough well that's what they say
but obviously we can see
we're at 25 000 feet i'm just saying
you'd think they'd be more of a
i know exactly how to train it the song
that took over the world
while we've been away uh making the
documentary
right was um which means
i think it's some sort of technical term
for mobile phones is a wireless
application protocol there you go
there you go i think we could read some
of the lyrics out some of the best
lyrics here we go
put this [__] right in your face swipe
your nose
like a credit card hop on top i want a
ride
i do a kegel while it's inside what's a
kegel uh it's where you tense your
vagina oh really
he got some money then that's where i'm
headed [__] a1
just like his credit he got a beard i'm
trying to wet it there you go she's
trying to piss on your face
right now you tell your butt right
because it's sweet good i ride on that
thing
like the cops is behind me obviously
we're trying to be uh sympathetic to the
people at this time
yeah there's a lot of police action
going on out there she's she's
conscious yeah she's trying to socially
link this in there's a lot of this is
layered like that yeah
oh and here we are again your honor i'm
a freak [__] handcuffs
leashes switch my wig make him feel
like he cheating very good honestly
honestly this is actually poetry
i actually do um love this song i think
it's encouraging women
too more sexually
confident right you know i'm saying so i
think more women should talk like this
get confident ladies yeah confident just
you know make him swipe his credit nose
like a credit cause
because what you find in in this day and
age is a lot of women you know they're
worried about what a man might say about
their body
in bed that sort of thing you own that
you're the queen where he had to enjoy
you
we're simply the moth and you are the
light there was a lot of backlash so
wasn't it look carol baskin
[Applause]
moral bastian carol baskin the woman who
probably killed her husband with her
[__] if women want to shake their ass
and talk about how great the [__] is i
am all for it
right let's just introduce uh televised
[__]
tucker carlson the song is called
w-a-p-wap
we can't tell you what that stands for
we literally can't tell you what the
name of the song is
you can say the word wet though so i
don't understand why he's not said that
wet is not a swear word here's the woman
who sings it cardi b
explaining to women how they can become
more useful sex objects
dry because your ph balance is off and
you wanna know why
it's not because you're born with it
it's because that keeps these dirtier
you gotta tell babe yo you're more like
mustard man
i won't throw my ph balance off the
thing about that she makes a good point
you gotta get your ph balanced right
she sounds like an absolute nut case
there yeah she's actually
spot on is she spot on no there was
another article that came out after that
which literally cooperated everything
she was saying right
ph balance and making sure that you're
actually
clean in getting head yeah it's not the
only reason that someone might have that
problem it's not because you're a dirty
person some people just have a problem
with their vagina
you know people are getting rich
pushing that crap on the country and
they should be ashamed of themselves but
they're not ashamed of themselves joe
biden just did an interview with cardi b
doesn't do a lot of interviews he just
did one with her he sucked up to her he
called himself joey b
i bet you did suck up to her yeah we
know what you're like joey old dog
yeah yeah joe walked in he went where's
that weird-ass [__]
call me joey b so we may be related or
something tell me what your
second name isn't b this guy you know we
may be related
look at them yeah look at them to be
fair they do have a similar
hairline timmy i wish we could be a lot
more specific and i'd be even willing to
go pretty far just to make the point
would you though yeah would you how far
would you go tucker would you suck my
dick
if there's one man i'd allow globally to
suck my dick it would be tucker carlson
i would love to see tucker carlson on
his knees just ramming my [__] to the
back of his throat
[Laughter]
and i'd i you know i'd say i'd look down
i really didn't expect without a word of
a lie
i'd look down and i'd go that's right
tucker
joe biden i have to say probably has no
idea
he probably had no idea who she is and
and what she's singing
that's no no not the point this not
because joe biden doesn't want to know
he's just incapable of withholding
information for more than five minutes
yeah he's got the memory of a goldfish
blossom i've got i've sent you a little
interview
actually for him he's oh forbidden yeah
he's struggling okay
this is joe biden describing what kovid
has done to america covet has taken this
year
just since the outbreak has taken more
than
100 years look here's the lives
it's just it's i mean you think about it
more lives this year than any other year
for the past hundred years right okay
for the past hundred years
right then what the any other illness
what then
what i think what he is trying to say is
more people have died this year
that from just from illness in america
than any other year in the past 100
years
right okay yeah well done lawrence
because you got that right you're now
running for the president yeah well i'm
the victim
though yeah to contrast that we've also
got donald trump's
uh just so anyone doesn't accuse us of
being on the left or on the right even
though it's quite clear where i'd like
to shove
my liberal dick and they throw the cans
of soup
that's better than a brick because you
can't throw a brick it's too heavy
but a can of soup you can really put
some power into that right
and then when they get caught they say
no this is soup for my family
to be fair sometimes could be a brick
for your family yeah this is building
the house
and they lay it in the ground and the
anarchists take it and they start
throwing it
at our cops at our police and if it hits
you that's worse than a brick because
it's got force
you're right i often worry about a kind
of stupid me
where does his expertise in having an
impact of a kind of suit come from has
that happened
he's probably seen i mean if anyone has
seen it can have soup impact on anyone
it's donald trump
yeah this my friends is a brick genius
it's the perfect size it's
like made perfect and when they get
caught they say no this is just
soup for my family yeah we don't you
know when toddlers just say the same
thing over and over and over again yeah
this is him
and then the media says this is just
these people are very very
innocent they're innocent people so this
is the problem
right now america have got to choose
between how you can barely speak
a man who is in cognitive decline and
clearly
in the early onset of like this dementia
alzheimer's that sort of thing he's
going through right now and joe biden oh
right yeah and then you've got donald
trump who i don't think is
anywhere near that level but is also a
bit mental
a bit mental yeah i mean narcissism
doesn't describe
they're both poor options the lesser of
two evils would be the best
i don't want to start anything this guy
went on a podcast
in a garden i don't know if i don't know
what to say i think this might be his
podcast
i'd like to see their true geordie
because they call me a racist
on one of their one of their podcasts
and that really broke my heart
and so [__] the true geode baby yeah do
not broke my heart
racism i'm confused by a few of these
things right i'd like to see true
geordie right um what would you what do
you think he'd do if we
saw him i don't want to go in on this
guy like that you know like i mean he's
a [__]
yeah he's just a lovely wrexham fan who
happened to
there was a time where you know he was i
i used to enjoy
a lot of the videos and we were having a
laugh at one of his videos
we actually used to regularly watch his
stuff right and we stumbled across one
video
just the one that he's referring to
where he said they as in
true geordie i guess at this point
called me a racist
i didn't really remember that but um
it's always worth
saying what was said what happened and
getting the truth out there so should we
have a little look yeah because i
haven't watched this video in about
since we made it i mean what the [__]
how long ago was that oh my god he went
to go our oven do you wanna have a look
at this
rovin is from goa the idiot returns
they filmed rovin's return to goa so
here's the context right we start to
watch the videos and then suddenly he
goes to goa our cameraman
who you know rovin is from goa we wanted
to know if rovin thought that this was
an authentic
realistic take on what an experience is
like going to go right okay yeah
what you're selling man what you're
selling
he's doing an accent and he's speaking
in a basic way it makes me feel wildly
uncomfortable i take this one
okay i take this one give me good price
okay 150
no can i just say that if if he's asking
for 150 rupees for the lighter
that lighter should not cost you more
than 30 rupees right
what i love is roving knows the prices
that's my favorite bit
which also shows what an authentic
golden rover is no he's the real
yeah you have bin laden sexy lady did he
just say bin laden
this is not acceptable just a casual bit
of racism and you're away to the bar
when you go to goa and you call a random
guy on the street who happens to be
asian bin laden yeah that is casual
racism
yeah it doesn't necessarily mean he's a
racist as you said
he's he broke his heart it doesn't mean
he's a racist but he's definitely being
[__] inappropriate and out of order i
am the last person to be the politically
correct police
however he crossed the line mate and if
if you think we're out of order
for saying that then it's wrong yeah
yeah although you can come and see us
i don't really want to see him if that's
all right yeah
of course just to be clear that's
because it's got better things to do
yeah and also if you upset roving you
upset us and off camera what we didn't
show
you actually offended our cameraman
quite badly with that sort of thing
because he is proud of goa he's proud of
where he's from
you go there basically take the piss out
the place and then you start calling
random people on the streets after
known terrorists yeah so i'm not saying
you are a dick but that was a dick move
right and when you act like a dick and
people say you're a bit of a dick there
what you're supposed to do is go yeah
i'm sorry about that yeah you're not
supposed to then
try not the big man on some podcast
because in your gazebo
it's disappointing because i actually
used to think he's pretty a funny guy
here but he's not
let's move on and with my life yeah it
doesn't affect us yeah they've
yeah have you ever been on britney
spears instagram page she's oh doesn't
she
i think she's a teenager like she's a
bit like peter pan does that make sense
she's a teenager for life now because
she's always doing
this sort of thing people are very
worried about it i think she knows what
she's doing i think she's pulling a
little bit of
um there was that um girl on youtube a
while back who pretended to go missing
remember the one who looked like she was
on drugs all the time there we go marina
joyce
she was bizarre yeah what's happened to
marina joyce now hey guys welcome back
to my channel today's video i'm showing
you how i do my hair
she comes across as very normal now do
you think she's dropped this
the act a bit what was in she can't go
missing anymore i've dropped the act of
going missing every week
a message from my boyfriend hey guys
welcome back to my channel today i'm
with my boyfriend
bootlegger son we're going to be making
a video that is so
accurate though hey baby hey baby
i was just yellow captain imagine him as
he's like basically what brandon did
is he did my fashion nervous shop for me
and yeah i just thought it'd be a fun
opportunity to have him choose the
clothes instead of me
and like what do these voice sounds like
very deep yes so yeah
so basically marina sent me on a mission
oh of course he's there
i love him he's actually got a bit of
charisma yeah he put a bit of a
permission
sent me on a mission she shot me on a
mission
the amount of outfits and what outfits i
want her to
wear in this video my favorite thing you
know when people are doing things as a
duo
on youtube is people who have to sit and
watch the other person talk so while you
talk i try to be as natural as possible
while i talk you try to be natural but
people don't even think of this phone
exactly but people in couple videos who
have to go
you ever seen this guy before do you
know what it is i really hope he's not
annoying oh right well you're not gonna
lie
you're not gonna like this guy very much
before he i hear anything he's gotta say
i thought he looks really annoying
you've nailed it there right you know
when i first met you i thought you're a
bit of a misogynist
sounds like you're not is that all turns
out you're actually all right i don't
think this guy's all right i've been
your best mate for [__] yes you could
i don't think this guy's redeemable
rules for picking up women in clubs rule
number five that a hair is
is offending yeah and this guy's
basically giving dating advice and then
how to get a girl home from the club
do you know back in like the early 2000s
they made all those high school movies
where they had like an annoying sort of
arrogant
wannabe model bit like of 10 things i
hate about you oh yeah
yeah i mean guys are like [__] but
they're not that much of an [__]
yeah and then you like you see a guy
like him and you're like [__] they got
me
or i'll say oh i have mario kart every
girl for some reason
every girl under the age of 25 is like
oh i'll kick your ass in mario kart
oh yeah prove it we've never once played
mario kart not once
you look like a rapist he looks like the
bad guy in a movie basically
yeah he comes across as the type of guy
who like after he licked the girl's
[__] or whatever would be like
really like scrubbing his tongue with
his toothbrush because he was so like
right
so like oh like oh that's dirty yeah i
wish we played mario kart yeah he's so
clean-cut though like he's annoying me
no shocker that when girls drink
they start to really loosen up i mean
the next thing you know they're dancing
like strippers
or they're making out with each other
and i spied on the other side of the
table a blonde asian girl with fake
cherries making out with one of our
friends and i'm like
perfect cherries yeah cherries he means
tits brian and when he sees it he goes
perfect in a six foot one well-dressed
white guy hitting on ablation is like
shooting with a handicap i mean it's
child's play
shooting on ablation yeah ablation is a
blond asian i'm guessing so and he calls
it child's play because he's a white guy
no no a well-dressed white guy what does
that mean
she should just be [__] great i don't
know yes weird isn't it so annoying
yeah well one more what is like dating
models in hollywood part five anyways i
haven't talked to the russian girls
since but whatever that's the nature of
the game they come and go
they've stopped talking to you and you
say that that's the nature of the game
they come in and go
just to be clear bro if these women
aren't ever calling you back for a
second dates
it's not coincidence it's not the nature
of the game it's this it's
cause you're in a new year yeah and
dating models in la is great because you
never have to worry about them being
like out of shape or gaining weight or
whatever because they're already so hard
on themselves
it's absolutely perfect that annoys me
because right so i
you know i prefer thick women right
they're feeling like they gotta
always be skinny because he men like him
tell them
telling them you have to watch what
you're eating and all this [__]
when actually what he should be saying
is however you are i love you
life isn't disney but at the same time
like it's men like him who like pile
pressure on women because they're weight
and [__] yeah he's an annoying [__]
you're beautiful how you are
we'll finish up on the big man or uh
yeah whichever one yeah okay
food reviewer i do reviews on the
youtube
you never knew such a cool i missed you
why because i know whether to buy that
foods all right guys what's going on
it's a fruitable
we're back uh dinner i think it's 8 30 1
20 today i love that he wears braces i
love him i love he has a van or a truck
it's it's also perfect we've watched him
grow up in front of our very eyes
still one of his he's looking more like
a man now i'd love to get his facial
hair coming through
he looks like he's working a regular job
out there just doing his bait i like it
i still want to meet him absolutely i'd
love to meet him i think he couldn't
give a [__] about us which is kind of
because normally when we promote people
they often get in touch they respond he
doesn't give two shits no but i rate
that even more i get that he's just like
me i'm doing my thing leave me alone
[__] off your true new [__] was once in
a group with him on instagram it's kind
of strange
yeah so we got a large steak and cheese
with extra cheese
no drink this guy i love him steak and
cheese
extra cheese a lot of meat looks real
good
not too sure how much cheese is on it
doesn't look too too greasy i mean
there's a little bit of grease up there
but that's expected
that is expected yes but also not too
greasy he's bang on with that
yeah but at the same time where's the
cheese it must be ingrained melted
inside the meat you know how sometimes
they cook burgers with cheese melted in
yeah yeah areas there's just a lot of
meat there isn't
it yeah i love him i love this guy so
much
and there is a good amount of cheese
down on the bottom of the sandwich
making everything all come together down
there but the top is just really dry
wow this is such in-depth analysis yeah
i actually feel like i'm eating it with
him
still looking around the eyes are doing
a bit of working out
i think it'd be better if the cheese is
more evenly distributed throughout the
steak
the fact that he's talking about
distributors when he's
he is talking about this as if he is a
ceo
of a company like if we could just sort
out the distribution
it's the cheese and meat sandwich is
what you're saying uh i'm impressed
i'll admit what i admire about him but
also what is part of a charm
is the level of seriousness that he
takes this to correct
he really feels like it's important i
get this right
and at times i have seen people in very
serious jobs
and very well paid jobs yeah not take
things seriously enough
and he's getting he's doing this for
free yeah and he's blessing us with
real insight there and not only that but
he most people just go yeah that's good
or you know all that food's nice he's
sort of going
no what you could have done here he's
thinking of alternatives yeah exactly
yeah yeah his mind is clearly thinking
that just flicks flakes everywhere is
amazing i'd love to know what's in the
bottom
like literally right if there's someone
who was starving to death in america
and they searched the footwell of his
car they'd have a face
yeah do you know what's amazing because
i know youtubers who spend
like hours of time energy money
on making content and they do not hold
me a [__] candle
this guy's sitting in his truck yeah
eating and just staring down the barrel
of the camera it's so great
yeah yeah it's it's can we go to dave
check the day about come on
right folks all right rock rocks uh oh
two days ago he did a mcdonald's triple
cheeseburger i am reviewing
a mcdonald's um it's new from mcdonald's
it's the uh triple cheeseburger i have
to check this out to be fair yeah to be
fair this does sound amazing
[__] the diet now you're probably going
to guess
what i'm going to say about this triple
cheeseburger
in 15 minutes dave i don't think so i've
actually done
the lancy air burger i went to the shell
thought
mcdonald's and i bought a phillio fish
i bought a chicken burger and i bought a
cheeseburger and i stacked them all up
and made
the burger the landscaping air burger
he's made his own burger
when he says air burger is he saying
that the chicken chicken can fly yeah
mm-hmm okay yeah i don't understand why
mcdonald's can't just like
tap into some of these ideas and
actually do what the people
[__] want give people what they want
see an air burger to be fair the reason
mcdonald's can't do it is because if you
combine those three burgers it'll become
incredibly
fat and sugar rich right so they can't
combine the three so they have to go
we can sell you these things separately
and you mix them yourself
maybe but also like also it's such a
mental thing to me
the fillet of fish with the cheeseburger
i don't like the sound of that together
so is he saying that you take them out
yeah basically but mcdonald's but they
should have a pickle on every
i have a young son right i've seen him
do similar things it's not the fact that
he sucks his fingers
no it's the way he grinds his teeth on
them and
really gets into the sucking
mid-sentence they should have a pickle
on every layer of beef
you know what i mean give it some
[__] flavor put some bloody effort
into it mcdonald's anyway i'm going to
tuck him what am i going to do june
the fact that he just not he's totally
unaware of like those little davisms
i just love it like we've been talking
about this guy for nearly two years now
he's never
he's never changed no you know what i
mean i love it which i really you know
i just don't think there's a lot of
taste in the beef but i think with all
the extra cheese
it's really made it it's literally more
of the same flavor yeah
what's going on i love it when dave uses
words like
you're getting the cheese coming through
yeah yeah
that he's going to do every time right
we're back take two
karen's pissing himself because we've
just done about five minutes and i got
the
[__] mic on look at this guy's face
straight away
i love these two have a friendship
because they're so the opposites
yeah yeah yeah looks what he's got on
though that's what he's got oh wow
got the merch on this will be the last
beer garden
weekly beer garden uh we're fighting
against the weather now
mate yes temperature the temperature it
also takes a chunk out of the weekend
day um i'm just going to conservatory
maybe this is a way of pioneers meat off
yeah probably the weather yeah and his
mate goes it's not raining today
uh looks like it could too could do it's
looking heavy for us to stand out here
and drink
four five six drinks you know we
sometimes we're going over we're going
after you yeah we're we're falling
asleep
what's happening is the wives are
moaning that they're getting shitfished
together
and now they're having to be like all
right then we'll knock it on the head
yeah you're like telling the camera
it's the weather yeah really the misses
are like yeah we're getting shit-faced
[__] off lovely uh before we go i also
want to say a huge thank you to everyone
who supported the rebuild documentary
big thanks to lawrence
smashdown together the team came through
and uh we're really happy about
how it started but also i'm training
every month now so we're going to be
putting out updates just once a month
yeah he trains once a month for a whole
day and we just film it and pretend
people know that it's on tg lawrence is
trying to film as many boxing sessions
as that as you can for me
we've already got some amazing bits the
next episode we've already yeah
they're not going to be quite the same
because that was sort of a real bring
you up the speed and then the next
episodes are going to be a lot more like
actual sessions but seeing what happens
but um yeah subscribe to tg2
and we'll show you a bit more of what's
going on and then you know hopefully at
the end you'll see me like uh graceling
and ripped you look great in this by the
way navy's really your color
yeah brings up the eyes yeah it does
yeah they're really pop
so big shout out to you lot once again
hit the like button subscribe for more
and we'll see you later